los funerales han comenzado en azerbayán
o un día después de que los
enfrentamientos fronterizos con armenia
mataran a decenas de soldados a ambos
lados los dos países han estado luchando
por la zona montañosa de nagorno karabaj
durante décadas pero esta es la
violencia más mortífera entre los
vecinos desde la pasada guerra de seis
semanas que mató a más de 6500 personas
en 2020 armenia dice que los bombardeos
azerbayanos han obligado al menos dos
mil 750 personas a huir de sus hogares
nos salimos y vimos que ya no era
posible permanecer en nuestras casas que
se estaba produciendo graves bombardeos
estábamos muy asustados huimos de las
casas para evitar quedar atrapados bajo
los extremos
los países exsoviéticos se han
intercambiado las culpas por el
recrudecimiento de las hostilidades
es evidente que esta agresión no fue
planificada con mucha antelación hubo
una larga campaña de propaganda de la
difusión de acusaciones casi
inimaginables de la llamada provocación
militar de armenia las rechazamos
constantemente
y armenia ha acusado a azerbayán de
ocupar una parcela de su territorio
tomada en los enfrentamientos del martes
y ha pedido ayuda a su aliado moscú
mientras tanto azerbaiyán ha recibido el
apoyo del pueblo del presidente turco
considerando inaceptable la violación
por parte de armenia del acuerdo
alcanzado tras la guerra de 2020 que se
saldó con la victoria de azerbaiyán
el mundo entero debe saber que como
siempre estamos al lado de nuestros
hermanos azerbaiyanos el mandatario
turco recep tayyip erdogán y su homólogo
ruso vladimir putin hablarán de los
combates cuando se reúnan esta semana el
kremlin ayuda a negociar un acuerdo de
paz entre bakú y ereván hace dos años
pero desde entonces moscú se ha
distraído con un su guerra en ucrania
que puede haber provocado un vacío de
poder que ha reavivado la atención